[Musica]
[Applauso]
nelle donne ogni cosa e cuore anche la
testa
immagino che recentemente abbiate
sentito nominare spesso il termine
resilienza la resilienza è la proprietà
dei metalli di piegarsi di fronte a un
urto senza mai rompersi è un termine
usato comunemente e metallurgia seta
settore dal quale professionalmente
deriva
allora mi sono chiesta ma sarà un caso
che questo termine abbia rappresentato
il filo conduttore di tutta la mia vita
professionale e personale
essere donna e amministratore delegato
oggi dell'impresa di famiglia che da
circa 50 anni si occupa di progettare e
costruire attrezzature per il
sollevamento in ambiti molto tecnici
molto maschili ambiti industriali navali
petroliferi non è stato facile ha
richiesto sicuramente una buona dose di
resilienza
unita però ha qualcosa di più a qualcosa
di che reputo essere tipicamente
femminile quella curiosità quella
passione quella lungimiranza
quell'audacia proprio la curiosità mi ha
portato nel corso degli anni a viaggiare
moltissimo viaggiare per conoscere per
farmi conoscere e per far conoscere la
mia impresa grazie a queste esperienze
abbiamo acquisito poi importanti
commesse che sono state oggetto di
soddisfazione per la famiglia e per
tutti i nostri collaboratori
la curiosità poi è una caratteristica
forse scritta nel mio dna famiglia
scusate l'audacia scusate è una
caratteristica forse un po insita nel
nostro dna familiare
l'audacia è quella caratteristica
appunto che ti permette di guardare
sempre oltre l'ostacolo no di affrontare
le difficoltà ma di saper cogliere le
opportunità chi pratica l'audacia attesi
a pratica un'apertura mentale
in forma di vita
certo lavorare in un contesto maschile
molto tecnico non è sempre stato facile
oggi ho pero giornalmente a fianco a
fianco con capocantieri ingegneri navali
che spesso mi vedono arrampicarmi sul
braccio di una gru a 20 metri di altezza
per controllare magari lo stato chiusura
di una fune oppure e scendere
all'interno di uno scafo di una nave in
costruzione
magari sotto gli occhi un po attoniti ed
impauriti degli operatori
però pensate anche quando nei viaggi che
vi dicevo prima
in alcuni paesi molto conservatori
ancora oggi ahimè per esempio l'arabia
saudita il qatar dove essere donne in
prima linea negli affari non è mai un
vantaggio anzi proprio una discriminante
quasi quasi una totale esclusione dal
business ma questi contesti così duri
così alle volte un po ostili non mi
hanno impaurito anzi mi hanno permesso
di tirar fuori quelle che sono forse
delle doti naturali di approvazione di
confronto e proprio in quei momenti di
difficoltà ho cercato di tirar fuori il
lato più positivo e migliore di me
nasco e cresco nella tipica impresa
familiare
l'impresa fondata circa 50 anni fa da un
uomo
mio padre un uomo che come sempre
succede in queste piccole realtà ha
sempre fatto è deciso tutto da solo
poi arriva inevitabilmente la seconda
generazione
una donna
beh indubbiamente inutile negare che
quelli piccoli scontri diciamo così
professionali ma anche familiari non
sono mancati però ancora una volta mi
sento di dire che proprio le qualità
femminili della donna della madre della
moglie in qualche modo la morbidezza la
diplomazia la democrazia che ci
contraddistinguono hanno permesso di far
sì che questi contrasti diventassero
delle opportunità cioè dei confronti
un motivo di crescita diciamo così per
entrambi
bene le imprese familiari noi sappiamo
che le imprese familiari sono la spina
dorsale del nostro tessuto economico
italiano sono imprese molto importanti
le piccole e medie imprese familiari
sono realtà appunto molto importanti e
ne abbiamo oggi qui ha avuto alcuni
esempi del territorio dove si trovano a
lavorare però sono anche realtà
difficili da gestire da portare avanti
si dice infatti che le imprese piccole
imprese familiari abbiano i problemi
delle grandi multinazionali ma noi
abbiano le risorse
non hanno le risorse finanziarie non
hanno le risorse organizzative e
manageriali
e purtroppo proprio le statistiche ci
dicono che nel passaggio generazionale
le imprese familiari hanno il loro
maggior motivo di default di fine le
statistiche proprio ci confermano che
nel passaggio tra la prima e la seconda
generazione
circa il 30 per cento delle imprese
familiari fallisce e quando
miracolosamente si passa diciamo così
questo primo scalino
nella tra seconda e terza generazione
ancora un ulteriore 13 per cento
non ce la fa
allora nella mia posizione e mi sono
chiesta ma qual è quindi il segreto la
chiave diciamo così la ricetta di un
corretto passaggio generazionale in
un'impresa familiare quando poi a capo
dell'impresa li trovi proprio la donna
beh ci ho pensato a lungo e poi anche
grazie un po l'esperienza di questi anni
ho pensato che indubbiamente è
fondamentale poter sempre dimostrare
soprattutto quando si è donna la propria
competenza la propria professionalità
professionalità relativa al proprio
settore ai propri prodotti ai propri
clienti perché sapete da un uomo ci si
aspetta che sia nel posto giusto al
momento giusto ma di una donna non
saprei quindi è sempre meglio poterlo
dimostrare
a questo poi mi sono sentita di
aggiungere diciamo così di ritenere
fondamentale il poter preservare il
saper preservare sempre nel passaggio
generazionale quelli che sono stati i
valori fondanti dell'impresa quei valori
che i nostri genitori ei nostri nonni
prima di noi hanno utilizzato per
fondare la loro realtà imprenditoriale
quei valori semplici familiari i valori
di serietà correttezza onestà verso le
persone e verso il lavoro perché
lavorava sempre visto come una grande
opportunità anche quando magari non
manca le cose vanno bene
infine vorrei chiudere questo mio breve
discorso ma andando appunto un messaggio
a tutte le giovani e meno giovani come
me imprenditrici che magari si accingono
oppure pensano di poter prendere le
redini della propria impresa di famiglia
e vorrei dire
non cercate di seguire necessariamente
la strada che i vostri predecessori
hanno creato e hanno segnato magari
anche per voi magari con successo ma
cercate di tracciare il vostro percorso
che sia del tutto personale e che
indichi la vostra unicità la vostra
passione le vostre capacità e che metta
soprattutto in gioco voi stesse e
ricordatevi sempre che in ogni donna
ogni cosa e cuore anche la testa grazie